.
CNN RETURN TO HIS IRISH
HOMETOWN TO SEE HOW THESE
FAMILIES ARE.
ADJUSTING
IT MAY BE THOUSANDS OF MILES
AWAY BUT CAHERCIVEEN, MY
HOMETOWN IS JUST ONE PART OF
IRELAND THAT'S BEING
TRANSFORMED BY THE WAR IN
UKRAINE.
HELLO, HOW ARE YOU, WHAT'S
GOING ON?
I WAS OVER ON A BICYCLE.
>> SIX WEEKS AGO WE WERE A
SCHOOL OF 103 PEOPLE, SEVEN
TEACHERS.
WE ARRIVED BACK FROM ST.
PATRICK'S WE CAN, TO A 50%
INCREASE IN OUR SCHOOL
POPULATION.
SIX WE LATER, WE HAVE 155
PEOPLES, AND TEN TEACHERS.
>> WITH A POPULATION OF ONLY 5
MILLION PEOPLE, IRELAND HAS
TAKEN IN MORE THAN 25,000
UKRAINIANS FLEEING THE WAR.
HUNDREDS HAVE COME TO
CAHERCIVEEN, AND EVERYONE IS
INVOLVED IN MAKING THEM FEEL
WELCOME.
>> I COME IN HERE MOSTLY WHEN
CLASSES ARE FINISHED.
THERE IS A BEAUTIFUL YOUNG GIRL
HERE.
SHE'S A CLASSICAL PIANIST.
SHE COMES IN AND PLAYS THE
PIANO WHEN THE SCHOOLS CLOSED.
SHE SERENADES ME FOR AN HOUR OR
TWO IN THE EVENINGS.
IT'S FANTASTIC.
>> HELLO MR. O'SULLIVAN, HOW
ARE YOU.
WHERE IS EVERYONE FROM?
>> I'M FROM KYIV.
>> YOU'RE FROM KYIV?
>> HOW LONG HAVE YOU'VE BEEN IN
CAHERCIVEEN?
>> TWO MONTHS, MAYBE.
>> YOU ARE AN EXCEPTIONALLY
TALENTED, PIANO PLAYER.
ARE YOU THE PIANO PLAYER?
IS THAT YOU?
DO YOU PLAY IN HERE?
>> YEAH.
>> AS WELL AS USING TRANSLATION
APPS, CAHERCIVEEN HAS HIGHER
TEACHERS TO HELP THE STUDENTS
LEARN ENGLISH.
>> OTHER GENERAL KNOWLEDGE IS
GOOD, IT'S JUST THAT THEY'RE
ENGLISH IS AT A LOWER LEVEL.
BUT THEY'RE LIKE SPONGES,
THEY'RE LOVELY CHILDREN.
THEY'RE ALL SMILES.
>> AS FOR THE IRISH STUDENTS --
>> I THINK IT'S A VERY NICE
EXPERIENCE, TO HAVE UKRAINIAN
PEOPLE IN OUR CLASS.
THEY CAN LEARN FROM US AND WE
CAN LEARN FROM THERE.
>> YOU'RE HAPPY TO HAVE SO MANY
NEW PEOPLE IN THE SCHOOL?
>> IT'S DIFFERENT, AND IT'S A
LOT BUSIER.
PEOPLE HAVE NEW FRIENDS NOW.
IT'S VERY NICE, I LIKE IT.
IT'S JUST SO LOVELY.
>> DESPITE LANGUAGE BARRIERS,
TO SEE PEOPLE ENGAGING,
LEARNING, HAPPY AND LAUGHING.
AND ADJUSTING.
OUR HUGE SUCCESS, TOTALLY
BECAUSE OF THE WHOLE COMMUNITY.
>> ACROSS IRELAND, UKRAINIAN
REFUGEES HAVE BEEN PLACED IN
HOTELS AND EMERGENCY
ACCOMMODATION, AND GRANTED THE
RIGHT TO WORK.
DESPITE STRETCHED RESOURCES,
MANY LOCAL COMMUNITIES ARE
HAPPY TO HAVE THEM.
>> IN THE SHOP, ABOUT FOUR OR
FIVE DAYS AGO, UKRAINIAN FAMILY
WAS BUYING STUFF FROM THE SHOP.
THEY WERE JUST ABOUT TO PAY THE
BILL, AND A LOCAL GUY STEPPED
IN AND SAID, NO.
HE HANDED ME HIS CARD AND SAID,
I'M GETTING THAT.
THEY WERE IN TEARS.
>> LILIA CAME HERE WITH HER TWO
CHILDREN AND HAS BEEN
OVERWHELMED BY THE IRISH
WELCOME.
BUT OF COURSE, STILL YEARNS FOR
HOME.
>> IRISH PEOPLE ASK US, ARE YOU
HAPPY?
AND, WE ARE TRYING TO BE HAPPY.
BECAUSE WE HAVE EVERYTHING,
THAT WE NEED NOW, HERE.
BUT WE DON'T HAVE --
LIFE.
IT'S KIND OF DIFFICULT, A
LITTLE.
>> BACK AT THE SCHOOL, YOU COME
IN HERE.
>> THIS IS MY DAUGHTER,
MARGARITA.
HER MOM CAME BY TO WATCH HER
DAUGHTER PERFORM FOR SOME OF
HER NEW IRISH AND UKRAINIAN
FRIENDS.
.